okay let's get started hello everybody
my name is Eric and I'm a graduate
student at MIT right now finishing my
fifth year in the biological engineering
department and it's my pleasure today to
show you through some of the
fundamentals of network analysis so
before we get started just a quick hand
show of hands how many of you are
feeling good this morning okay awesome
we want some positivity in the room if
you haven't already please download the
github repository either git clone or
download the zip file if you are not
planning to code today that's completely
fine I encourage you then to pair up
with someone who's at a computer
terminal so that you can actually try
out some of the hands-on exercises a
note about today's tutorial I'm not
going to talk much I have five minutes
worth of lengthy content and then
there's a lot of you trying out some of
the exercises that are inside there and
another note is that I'm used to having
this tutorial be three hours long and so
usually what I've done is I've
interspersed little bits of me talking
with youth coding and then I've waited
for about 80% of the class to say okay
I'm good and then we'll move on so a
note about that it's perfectly fine if
you don't finish the activity the idea
is that you've been thinking about it
and you've tried something secondly
because we only have an hour and 40 ish
minutes I'm going to reduce that 80%
threshold to 40% so if I see 40% of
people more or less done I'm gonna move
on and like I said if you didn't finish
don't worry it's totally okay
third thing about the format the the
structure if you look inside the github
repository
they're usually for most notebooks there
are two versions there's an instructor
version and then there's a student
version obviously in this instructor
version all the answers are coded there
if you follow along with the instructor
version all right I can't do anything
but if you want maximum benefit please
follow along using the student version
all right I'm gonna give everybody just
a very very quick quiz because you're
going to see this coding pattern a lot
what's a plausible data structure for my
favorite things and s do we have any
volunteers dictionary for s yep and my
fav things is probably a some iterable a
list ok great
if you all could understand that means
you're good to go for this class because
that's really the level of Python that's
required
apart from also understanding you know
functions what they return really you're
gonna see a lot of this coding pattern
if you read the readme or if you read
the preface notebook you can use the
check n PI scripts of Python check n PI
and it'll check your environment it's
something I threw up last night or
something just to make sure people could
you know check make sure everything's ok
there's also an environment yml yeah
mole file inside there and so if you use
kondeh and we all love anaconda we all
love continuum analytics so if you use
condo ends you can use the environment
of yml file and i want to give credit to
dan for pointing out the errors in my
one
yamo file this morning all right
so all of that administrative stuff that
I went through downloading the repo
checking your environment if you want to
take the next 5 minutes of me talking to
just focus on that no problem go ahead
and do that in the meantime I'm going to
talk through some of the motivation for
some of the content in this tutorial so
you all are here to learn about the
fundamentals of network analysis and
what we're going to do is we're going to
go through some of the basic algorithms
and mostly algorithms really we're going
to go through some of the basic
algorithms in network analysis as well
as things to look out for in a network
so I want to get some definitions out of
the way first networks are a kind of
data structure in computer science terms
they're also called graphs and their
definition is extremely simple its
circles and lines or in other words in
more
technical terms its nodes and edges
nodes represent entities they could be
airport stations they could Airport
Terminal sorry they could be
transportation links hub sorry
and then edges represent the
relationships between these entities so
for example we might talk about an
airport air transport network where
we've got planes flying from terminals
terminals so one thing that I'm hoping
that you will take away from today's
tutorial is that you'll learn to think
in terms of edges and not in terms of
nodes in other words I'm hoping you'll
learn to think in terms of relationships
between entities and not just the
entities themselves we're used to basic
stats right basic stats talks about how
many how many football players are in in
in what's the distribution of football
players in high school football teams
but we rarely talk about the friendships
between or the the the the matches that
are played between these football teams
right or we don't talk about the people
and their interactions on the team and
how they the the relationships and
interactions can give rise to winning or
losing stats so I'd like to one of my
goals for tip for today is to have you
go back thinking in terms of
relationships between entities and not
just the entities themselves and to take
a quote from a professor at the Harvard
School of Public Health it's not
published anywhere so you can't verify
it you just have to take my faith on it
he mentioned it at a network analysis
seminar that I had attended basically
the heart of a network lies in its edges
and not in its nodes so I hope you'll
ponder over that throughout today's
tutorial there are generally two types
of networks because relationships can be
unidirectional or they can be
bi-directional or they can not have any
direction and so we have directed and
undirected graphs and in today's
tutorial we'll only be dealing with the
undirected version because it's the
similar simpler version to deal with
so wanted to I gave some examples of
networks just now there's air
transportation networks there's you know
Facebook is a social network in which
the nodes are users and then the edges
are whether users are friends with each
other I just wanted to throw it out
throw this question out there to
everybody you know what other networks
have you all heard about any volunteers
that disease spread network so contact
networks or you know the actual
transmission networks absolutely that's
my that's a right up my alley actually
hyper link network so links between web
pages anything else
balance sheets how is that a network
that's an interesting way I've never
heard of that Wow okay that's the first
thing I've heard it's a it's really good
it's a really good example so in today's
class we'll try to what I'm going to
show you is also a glimpse of how to
model a problem as a network and how to
extract useful information from that
network of stuff specifically by the end
of this tutorial
practically speaking you should be able
to use the network X package to
construct graphs in the Jupiter
environment because we're all using
Jupiter notebooks today secondly you'll
have a recognition of some common
network visualization methods so node
link diagrams heat maps circo's plots
and hive plots you should be able to
implement basic algorithms to find
structures and paths inside a network
and finally and this is the this is the
most fresh content it's also what I
think the most exciting content you
should be able to do statistics on
networks using C musing hacker hacker
methods right and so I'll give you a
little bit more
background when the time comes and as I
was mentioning earlier in broader terms
think in terms of interactions and think
through statistical problems in network
analysis alright so that's it for me
talking on and on and on and on and on
we're going to get started with the
coding challenges right now so what I'd
like you to do is open up notebook
number two I'd like you to open up
notebook number two and what we're going
to do in this notebook is have you
become a bit more familiar with the
network X API
alright the function calls that are
available to you and how you can use the
network shape network X API to make
queries on a graph so for this tutorial
I've created a synthetic social network
it's not based on any real data and
we're going to use the synthetic social
network throughout the class to explore
all of that so before we continue just
want to make a few points about how
Network X represents networks right so
Network X represents networks in terms
of a graph or a directed graph object
alright and under that object there are
two attributes one is called node and
what is one is called edges edge sorry
nodes are dictionaries so you'll use
dictionary accessor methods quite a lot
edges are also dictionaries except they
are dictionaries of dictionaries if I'm
not remembering correct incorrectly it's
either dictionary of dictionary or
dictionary of dictionary of dictionaries
one of those two all right and so with
edges you'll be also using dictionary
methods a lot and so when you want to
store an object store an item as a node
in network X you have to make sure that
they are a hashable object so strings
tuples okay lists and sets not okay
generally people
use strings integers and stuff because
they carry meaning that's human
understandable
so in this social network we're going to
answer the following questions below how
many people are present what's the
distribution of attributes how many
relationships and what's the
distribution of number of friends each
person has in the synthetic social
network all right so let's load it up if
you could run this cell G dot G equals
NX dot r EG pickle and that will load
the synthetic social network into memory
and it'll have the variable name g over
there all right so just run that cell
really quickly so let's get started oops
let's first understand how many people
are present inside the network so the
function call for getting the list of
nodes that are present is G nodes
oops user so if you could run this cell
here G nodes you will see that we've got
0 1 2 3 4 5 and what it's what G nodes
has done is its returned a list of
integers and that's because the integers
are the nodes inside the network and G
dot nodes will return an iterable list
so what I'd like you do to do now is to
take 30 seconds to write a single line
of code that returns the number of
individuals represented
and when you're done please just give a
thumbs-up okay okay all right good good
I saw it sorry all right we wait for
just a few more people and if you're
done don't forget please give the thumbs
up all right so if you've got len g
nodes great if you assigned it to some
variable or something else totally no
problem the point is it's an iterable
right so we can we can calculate its
length all right if we then want to
understand the relationships in the
network we look at the edges and so
network x also provides an API for
accessing the edge list that's present
inside the network and so we've got so
so the edge list essentially lists every
edge that's present inside there as a
tuple a 2-tuple in which you have if it
was a directed network would be source
and sink but if it's an undirected
network it would be just the two nodes
that are linked together with order not
being important all right so likewise
take ten seconds now to write a single
line of code that returns the number of
relationships present inside the network
and you're done please give the thumbs
up okay
saw you guys so you guys are you all any
more good I see you guys see you all
good very good
all right so if you got Len G edges
great that's it should be for for the
level of Python that we're dealing with
in this class I believe it should have
been trivial if it wasn't that's no
problem
maybe that Network X API is a bit
unfamiliar and what it's returning in
stuff don't worry with time and practice
this gets this becomes something that is
reflexive all right networks can store
metadata so a node can have properties
right I can have an individual I can
have that individuals age and I can have
the gin dividuals gender right I can
also have metadata associate
with with the edges right so I can say
if a and b know each other i can store
along that edge what date that
friendship or that knowledge of each
other was formed all right
so in the network x api if you do g
nodes and you pass in the parameter data
equals true you will get a 2-tuple a
list of two tuples in which the first
element is the node and the second
element is a dictionary of all of the
metadata that's stored inside that
dictionary it's stored for that node all
right so if you run that cell that's
what you'll get what I'd like to give
everybody now is a two minute coding
challenge problem which is to count the
number of males and females that are
represented inside the network and as a
hint you may want to use the counter
object from the collections module right
I'm just going to flash this up here
because the coding activity is all
present inside your notebooks as well so
I I'm going to flash this up here so you
can have at least a visual
representation of what's being returned
and then likewise when you're done
please give a thumbs up okay great
okay I see more hands great I see
another one I'm gonna give you guys a
hint of the well I'll just show the
answer for now and then I'll I'll maybe
talk through the answer all right so
what we're doing is we're saying we're
iterating over the nodes actually you
know what I'm gonna do a longer windowed
version of this guy
so let's comment that out so how one
would do it in a non list comprehension
way would be to go M equals 0 and F
equals zero so male and female and then
we go for node in G nodes data equals
true keeping in mind that now node is a
2-tuple we want to access the the second
element we'd go node if node one equals
if node 1 and and node 1 is a dictionary
so when we can use dictionary accessors
then we do F plus equals 1 else M and M
plus equals 1 and then we can print F
and M hmm okay very interesting I must
have had I've added two people it should
be 15 15 not 16 16 and that's I've added
two more people inside the network later
on and that's part of the API so if if
you got fifteen fifteen that's cool but
a more compact way of doing it is to use
a list comprehension so I'm going to
take this out and if we take a look at
this we're saying we're unpacking the
2-tuple that comes in for nd in G nodes
right so we're iterating over two tuples
so we can unpack the tuple in the for
statement and then we can access the the
biological sex of that individual and
then over here because we're
encapsulating it inside a list
comprehension we'll get a list of male
male female male male female female
female male male female right and then
the counter object will take that that
list of thing
and summarize it as male and female and
like I was saying I added two
individuals later on so it's supposed to
be 15 and 15 all right
so that's sort of the this list
comprehension way of thinking I'd like
you guys to start thinking in terms of
list comprehensions as well it's a very
compact way to express how you what
you're querying for inside the network
so likewise edges can also store of
attributes I was mentioning earlier so
if you do if you run the cell below
you'll do you'll get GE edges data
equals true all right and so inside this
data structure that's returned it's a
list of three tuples where you have the
two nodes as the first two elements and
then you have the dictionary of
attributes that is the third element
right and so that's this guy over here
and so there's a date that stores a
date/time object that stores what date
on on which date these friendships or
relationships were forged so as the next
so date/time objects just so that you
you know they have attributes as well
and you can access their Year month and
day it's just a little tidbit of
information all right so as the next
exercise can you figure out the range of
dates during which these friendships
were forged likewise again I want you to
think in terms of list comprehensions so
try that out and specifically I want you
to compute the earliest and the last
date of these relationships all good
okay please give that a shot
and if you're done please give me a
thumbs up
I'm using Python 3 so if you're on
Python 2 I've created an environment
llamo file that should give you that you
can use Conda ends with there's a readme
follow the instructions there and if
you're finding it
you're if you're finding that you're
falling behind a little too much don't
worry go and pair up with someone else
who's got the right environment the
important thing is to talk through the
problems so how many people are done
just to give a quick show of thumbs okay
we'll wait we'll wait a little longer
and if you're done just give a quick
thumbs up right
so as I was mentioning if you're
struggling with the there's there's
instructor and student versions of the
notebook so if you're struggling you
want a hint go ahead look at the
instructor version as well and that's
fully applicable to this notebook plus
all of the other notebooks that are up
there how are people doing
so I'm just gonna flash up the answer up
there if you got something like that or
if you know at the minimum if you got
two thousand two zero five two zero and
then twenty eleven 11:04 you know then
that's that's great that's basically it
all right and there's just so that you
know right we're just let you know we're
also using the list comprehension coding
pattern this is a coding pattern I want
to hopefully transmit to everybody it's
very useful for very compact queries on
the network alright so let's continue on
we found out that there are two
individuals that were not added so that
was why I had 16 individuals 16 and 16
not 15 and 15 you guys don't have that
just yet so what I'd like you to do is
to use the G dot add node and G dot add
edge functions to introduce this data
that I'm describing up here alright and
I've proved I have provided starter code
an example add node in an example add
edge for you to model off
that's right that's right so if the node
is already present it just silently
overrides over writes that node that's
present
okay how many people are done can you
give a thumbs up alright we'll wait just
a few more minutes
any new completers okay okay great all
right so if you got this perfect and I
provided a little example of how to
access the metadata for a particular
notes if you know the node label in this
case it's 31 then cool you can also do
the same with edges so if you do edge 31
32 you'll get the what's returned is the
the dictionary attribute all right if
you do I think if you do 31 if you do
edge 31 so you only provide one of the
nodes in the edge what you'll get is a
dictionary of dictionary so you'll see
the key is the other individual that
it's connected to and the date and then
the metadata that's associated with that
as well all right okay and if you ran
that cell then cool you should have an
all test pass if you got an all test
pass that's good I didn't test for
everything but you know that's just a
quick quick and dirty test test function
that you can use so just a very quick
note about tests I am I guess a pseudo
data scientist I don't really know what
you would call a PhD student doing
analytics we've all heard about testing
your code right testing your code so
writing tests writing unit tests doing
automated you know what is this Travis
CI automate continuous integration then
you add in a PI dot test bash call
inside there testing is good when you're
writing code testing is also good for
your data if you're doing data analytics
you'll want to ensure the integrity of
your data things that you expect to be
true about your data should be true in
the actual data that you get if you're
planning to log ten transform something
you can't have things be negative valued
or zero valued so you'd want to write a
test for that particular column of data
and so
writing tests is important I've given a
lightning talk on this I'd encourage you
to I'd like I'd encourage you to check
it out see if it's in if it's of
interest for you all I think tests are a
great way a great automated written
contract between you and your data all
right and and if the data keeps changing
you'll want to write tests for to make
sure to ensure data integrity also this
thing about defensive programming
software carpentry has a great tutorial
on that I'm not going to mention any
more except put put that URL out there
for you all okay so I was mentioning
coding patterns list comprehensions
they're big especially when you're doing
with network data you're doing recursion
a lot you for things that are one level
deep use a list comprehension don't use
a for-loop because if you're doing
algorithms on networks you're going to
be using nested nested nested for loops
and or you're going to use a lot of
recursion in networks so as far as
possible keep your code contact compact
as in keep your code compact basically
that's my message I've listed out here
things for your reference that you can
reference in later notebooks or you know
beyond this tutorial if you'd like as
well so iterating over nodes iterating
over edges like I was mentioning if
there are if you're using a directed
graph sorry if you're using an
undirected graph you would use n 1 & 2
for example is in your list
comprehension or if you're using a
directed graph you may want to choose
your variable names in a way that is
informative for yourself so source and
sync might be a better variable name
instead fine okay so the final part of
this notebook is on drawing graphs and I
have no coding challenges there I just
want to quickly run through an overview
of how you would draw networks this
using NX draw G is the most common way
that you'll see in academic papers in
online visualizations etc you'll see a
hairball and it's a hairball by the time
you get beyond 30 to 50 nodes if it's a
small network node link diagrams are
okay if you're gonna talk about a
thousand node network please do
use a node link diagram it ends up
looking like a hairball instead so sorry
if so like I was saying if you have if
you have nodes if you have your network
being small enough you can enlarge the
size of your node you can add in visual
labels and stuff with the network X API
but like I was saying please don't use
it if your network is beyond 30 to 50
nodes in size so another way of
visualizing the network is to use a
matrix right and so a matrix
representation looks something like this
over here in which on the x axis you
list all of the nodes and on the y axis
you list all of the nodes and with a 1
or 0 let's say it's an unweighted
network with a 1 or 0 you can indicate
whether a relationship exists or not
you'll notice that essentially either
the bottom half of this matrix is CIFOR
the top half is sufficient to represent
all of the data if it's an undirected
network because they're symmetrical
along the diagonal if however you have a
directed network where I may know you
but you may not know me then you'll need
the full matrix to represent all of the
data all right recently I think and and
by recently it's with respect to network
visualization history recently there's
been two innovations that I really like
to visualize interactions and networks
and they are the circles plot and the
hive plot an undergrad that worked with
me helped me implement the circles plot
in Python previously there was no such
thing available for pythonista
so we built on top of the matplotlib api
oopsies and we're able to create
something like this in which all of the
nodes are ordered in a circle around in
this around the circumference of a
circle and then edges are drawn in this
way between them right and so if you go
online circo's dot CA so it's it's a
built-in it was invented in my homeland
of Canada in Vancouver my home city yes
thank you Canadians all right
so so is invented of circo's CA you'll
get to see some example visualizations
circles plots were initially used for
genome visualizations they're a very
highly aesthetic way of visualizing
network data right and over here you can
see there are two nodes that are
unconnected inside the network and that
should correspond exactly with what we
see inside a node link diagram so
finally let's try the hive plots and so
again nobody's implemented hive plots
for Python so I wrote my own utility to
make a hive plot the API is kind of ugly
because I'm not really a programmer so
please forgive me for that that said
it's on Khanda it's on pip I haven't
released circo's yet because we're still
making a few more bugs bug fixes over
there but if you take a look at that
this is the social network that we're
visualizing over there and what what
we've done is we've grouped it's a
rational way in my opinion of
visualizing networks you show the
structure of the network with respect to
certain properties that are inside that
network so if we group the nodes we've
got a group here and a group up there we
can look at the intergroup relationships
and the intra group relationships all
right and we can get a visual feel for
how the structure of the network is
influenced by the metadata inside the
network alright so yes yes that's right
so that's a very good point
so within so if you want to visualize if
you're only interested in a hive plot if
you're only interested in intergroup
relationships
you wouldn't clone the axes you'd have a
single axis so a blue axis and a red
axis and that would look very much akin
to sayyou you'd have those flat line
things where you'd have arcs being drawn
between nodes inside the network so that
would be akin to that now here to look
at the intra group relationships rather
than drawing messy self loops on there
the way to the way that it's done is one
clones the blue axis and one clones the
red axis and now we're able to see the
the in the relationships but within the
red group and
blue group all right yes so let's see
let's see let's see let's see what have
I seen before so I've seen protein
interaction networks right and there are
a zillion proteins that are inside the
body and we know whether they are in
contact with one another or not those
proteins can be grouped by their general
function so for example you can have
things that are involved in metabolism
I'm sorry you can have things that are
involved in sugar metabolism you can
have things that are involved in fat
metabolism you can have things that are
involved in protein metabolism and then
you can ask are these interacting with
one another are these proteins that
belong to disparate groups interacting
with another or are they interacting
more within their own group all right
and I think the answer is they are
interacting more within their own group
if you're interested in biology so
that's one application and here we have
another where so that the core idea the
abstract idea is group your nodes and
then see the relationships intra and
Inter group all right okay all right so
that's it for the introduction to the
network x api plus a bit of drawing
networks yes yes yes yep yep yes
absolutely
there's more there's more that's
available inside the network X package
absolutely there are also lots of
research into drawing algorithms to draw
networks in an efficient way I'm not
going to go through them I'm actually
personally not very well versed in that
myself
there's the force-directed layout which
you know d3.js has implemented as well
and I've played
but we all know JavaScript's a little
bit of a pain in the neck to work with
so haven't really played any further
beyond copying what's on Mike Bosse
stocks web page right so that's
basically it
but yes networks that are small enough
by all means go use note link diagrams
there it's great because you can get a
feel for it but like I was saying
hairballs once you get to thousands of
nodes like if you've seen those big big
ones even if you color it you can't
really see clearly where the edges are
being drawn etc and like I was saying or
like John Quackenbush had said the heart
of a network is in its edges not in its
nodes okay so with that let's close up
notebook two and I'd like to have you
open up notebook number three and in
this notebook what we're going to do so
please run that first cell before we
continue please run that first cell
inside the notebook so in this notebook
what we're going to do is we're going to
try to look at the structure of the
network so previously we had been
interrogating you know what's the edge
list what's the what's the node list now
we're going to look a little bit closer
at the structure of the network and see
if we can identify individuals that are
important in this synthetic social
network so one may say that so if we go
to a networking conference you might say
that the butterfly networker
is someone who is of great importance to
this community because that butterfly
networker is connected with a lot of
people he or she is talking with a lot
of people at that conference and has a
lot of links a lot of relationships to
other individuals so one approach that
we could use is to use a neighbors
approach we can ask and say we what we
can do is we can ask how many people are
is is this individual connected to in a
network and so network X provides a G
neighbors node with a
parameter node function that lets us
figure out the number of individual
individual has so I've listed here G
neighbors nine we can do number seven
and we'll see that number seven is
connected to number 24 and 25 you can
change that to one and you'll see one is
connected to a few different set of
people so what I'd like you to do what
I'd like you to try to do is to create a
ranked list of the importance of each
individual based on the number of
neighbors that they have right and I've
provided you with a few hints that you
might want to use to tackle this problem
and when you're done likewise please
give a thumbs up
okay I see another thumb see another
hand see another thumb see a fist okay
okay I see another hand
okay so you know just to give an overall
feel how many people are done if you
could just raise your hand one more time
okay okay so as as I was mentioning
earlier because of time constraints
we're gonna do with a we're gonna deal
we're gonna use a forty percent
threshold as a determinant to move on so
I think we're roughly at about 40
percent of the classroom today so right
now so if you got something like this
it's not showing completely up here
again I was I'm trying to encourage you
to use the list comprehension way of
looking at it
and so we encapsulate we first get a
list of nodes but then we sort them by
the length of their neighbors and so
I've used the lambda function if you had
an alternative way of looking at it
totally no problem like well you know
like most coding problems there's
usually more than one one solution
that's feasible but really you should
have nineteen at the top and you got 19
at the top then kudos to you because 19
is the most connected inside this
network alright so number of neighbors
is one approach we could also use the
degree centrality approach right and so
the degree centrality is actually based
on the definition of number of neighbors
and and the definition of degree
centrality is the number of neighbors
that a node has normalized to the number
of individuals it could be connected to
in the entire graph right excluding
itself if you include itself if you
include self links then that's a
different mathematical definition if you
exclude self links that definition
changes all right so what we can do is
we can get the degree centrality of the
the distribution of degree centrality is
by using this function call NX degree
centrality G looks like it's stalled on
me okay let's let's try this again so
if you run that cell you'll get and if
you run n X degree centrality G what
it'll do is it'll return a dictionary
and the dictionary will show zero
you know the node ID followed by that
mathematica mutation of its degree
centrality which is number of neighbors
divided by number of total potential
neighbors nope it that really is just it
number of nodes in the graph - so
depending on whether you include
yourself or not - one or without the
minus one so what I there are other
measures of centrality they're all
implemented in the network X API they
all have different mathematical
definitions and so what that means to
your network analysis will change
depending on what question you're asking
and so you use different measures of
centrality right so take some discussion
thinking and debate to figure out what
centrality measure to use in any case I
want you guys to do this I want you to
create a histogram of the distribution
of degree centrality x' and then do
likewise do the same for the
distribution of the number of neighbors
and then create a scatter plot of the
degree centrality is against the number
of neighbors
and if you're done with one and you
don't want to do too you can skip right
to three and that's totally okay
and because question for was answered
we're just we're not going to go through
that today
and if you'd like to you you could also
compare your answer against the
instructor notebook to see whether you
got roughly the right answer
and then don't forget when you're done
please give a thumbs up
so just want to get a quick feel how
many people have done one okay great how
many of you are attempting to right now
okay great and how many of you are
attempting three right now okay great
exactly and that's really the point if
you see so let me just put this down put
this up here for you guys it should be
exactly linear and that comes right
straight from the mathematical
definition and it's so all of this
should just tie right back with each
other right the mathematical definition
of the degree centrality is based on the
number of neighbors so number of
neighbors and degree centrality should
become perfectly linearly related
alright now that we got that point out
that's great we can move on to the next
activity so centrality by number of
neighbors is a great way to think
through who might be a an important yes
sorry ah yeah okay so exercise four is
how many possible edges are are there in
total assuming self edges are allowed if
there are n nodes including yourself and
you're allowed then you are and you're
allowed to be connected to yourself then
there are n possible total edges and
then self self edges are not allowed and
sorry I mean this in an undirected
network so in an in a directed network
there's actually two n minus 1 number of
edges that are allowed that's right
so so from one node edges that are
allowed in a directed network could be I
know you and you know me so it's to per
other node but then if I know myself and
I know myself they're identical then we
take one out right so 2n minus 1 and
then if self edges are not allowed in an
undirected Network if there are n nodes
I exclude myself there n minus 1 people
I could be connected with
okay so now that we got this linear
relationship out of the way let's talk
about paths in a network all right so
graph traversal requires that you be
able to look graph traversal requires
that you be able to trace out a path on
the network and it's useful if you're
talking about message passing problems
or you know infectious disease spread
based on contact you want to reconstruct
things like that one of the algorithms
that's pretty cool is you know how do
you find the shortest path from one node
to another node and so if we draw that
network again like I'm breaking my own
rules by showing it to you as a hairball
no I'm not really actually it's less
than 30 in size so if we we draw that
we'll notice that there are certain
individuals for which in the network you
could never draw a path to it from
another node and then there are other
people who are connected with one
another and so we could draw paths we
just might not take if we're not careful
we might not take the shortest path
right so how would you find the shortest
path between two nodes one approach is
to take a breadth-first search approach
in which you start if you if you say i
want to start at this node and i want to
get to a destination node i'll search by
looking first at the first degree of
separation and seeing whether my
destination node is there and if it's
not there i'll iterate over all of the
neighbors two degrees out and so forth
and so forth and so it's this is not
necessarily fastest but it's the easiest
conceptualize so that's essentially the
approach I've given you the pseudocode
for that what I'd like you to try is to
implement an algorithm in a function
called path exists node 1 node 2 you
pass in two nodes and you pass in the
graph and it should return a boolean
that indicates whether a path exists
between these two nodes or not and I'm
going to break pythonic conventions and
say also print out whether it's that
whether a path exists or not so don't
just return true or false
also print you know it exists or doesn't
exist
and so this notion of paths will tie
into our idea of centrality in a moment
and I'm hoping that you'll follow me
along with this
so I'm gonna put back up not the
exercise prompt but the pseudocode that
you might need on the screen just in
case it's a little too far up while
you're writing your code and just want
to re-emphasize if you've not been
completing the exercises in time as we
go along in the class like I said it's
completely ok these challenges these are
coding challenges these are not mere
coding problems so they are designed to
be to exercise the mind
okay I see a thumbs up
I see thumbs up thumbs up thumbs up
thumbs up thumbs up
oh yes that's right yes that's right my
apologies got the pseudocode wrong
thanks for the catch
what's your github handle at 7:00 ca va
sorry
okay all right just a note for myself
okay so just want to get a quick feel
for this problem how many people are
done please raise your thumb okay we're
we're at threshold so if you got
something like this great like as this
is exactly a straight-up implementation
of the yeah it's a straight-up
implementation of the of the of the
pseudocode and if you do a test on you
to run a few tests like I was mentioning
tests are important for your code you
should be able to see that path does not
exist between eighteen and five because
they're not connected anybody and a path
does exist between 29 and 26 all right
so I will admit this was a bit of a
bait-and-switch this algorithm has
already been implemented in network X
you don't have and a lot of likewise a
lot of these algorithms have also been
implemented in network X you don't have
to implement a lot of these things
yourself all right
Network X has taken care of a lot of
these things so if you do has path g18 5
and X dot has path you know you'll get
the same result there all right so
shortest path is is a function that we
can use it's different from has path
right has path is simply does a path
exists shortest path is what is the set
of nodes that I have to traverse through
to get from one node to the destination
node while hopping through a minimum
number of nodes right and so it'll give
us a list of nodes corresponding to one
of the shortest paths of course not all
paths are guaranteed to be found but
that's ok if we're only interested in
the shortest path so what I want you to
try to do is to extract just the sub
graph that is induced from this set of
nodes plus its edges all right and so as
a hint here so this function called G
dot sub graph nodes of interest is a
useful thing if you're looking to only
analyze a
set of nodes inside the graph and that's
why we call it a sub graph so what wants
you to try to do is to you know use take
30 seconds to write a single line of
code that implements this extraction
that extracts and returns this sub graph
and when you're done please again give a
thumbs up let me just check a few things
right
okay so how are people doing with this
if you're done please give a thumbs up
or raise your hand okay good
wait a few more minutes
you
okay I see a few more hands great
okay just to get a feel for things how
are people doing all right okay we'll
wait for two more hands just two more
hands
one hand
anyone else
okay
I'm just gonna quickly flash up this the
answer on the screen or we've done is
we've asked whether there's a whether a
path exists we use the has path and if
the path exists then we'll use the
shortest path will extract the nodes out
and then we'll get the subgraph of those
nodes all right and so and then of
course if the path does not exist then
we'll put there you know we'll raise an
exception over there all right yes
that's right so if you if you extract
the nodes if you pass in the list of
nodes automatically it'll give you the
edges as well part of me
so other edges you mean four and
fourteen yes it would so if if well you
know that's a good point
let me mmm let me close this
presentation mode and let's add let's
let's shortcut that all right let's add
an edge between 1 and 14
I'm gonna forget about the metadata and
then we'll do
and then we'll do that so note the old
one at the top which didn't have that
shortcut between 4 and 14 note the new
one in which I added a shortcut between
4 and 14 and so what's returned now is
just 1 for 14 without all of the stuff
in the middle all right all good all
right boo I'm gonna have to restart my
kernel now no I don't have to actually
it's ok all right
so in the interest of time I'm going to
skip over the following exercises over
here because they're all about drawing
stuff to screen and so I encourage you
to go back and look at them inside the
notebook there's there's also a
challenge exercise in which we do a
little bit more fancy math on the
network go ahead try that at home we
don't really have the time to cover it
here but that's totally no problem
because they're all extensions of what
the fundamentals that we've gone through
so far so what I want what I want to do
is actually skip right down to the
bottom and take a look at this notion of
hubs being revisited all right what is a
hub a hub is not necessarily something
that's connected to everybody a hub can
also be something through which messages
have to pass through it could be a
bottleneck right a bottleneck in some
sense is also a hub so what I want you
to try to do is to plot the between the
centrality against the degree centrality
for the so synthetic social network that
I've given you over there so give that a
shot
and so just to give you all the starting
point I think I've given you degree
centrality equals something and it
should be a function call NX degree
centrality if you look at the bottom of
the screen there I deliberately not
scrolling up because I don't want to
reveal the whole answer if you look at
betweenness centrality likewise you'll
get the dictionary matched to of nodes
matched to its between the centrality
and the betweenness centrality like I
was mentioning earlier is how many
shortest paths have to pass through that
particular node in the network all right
so let me see if I can blow this up a
little bit okay big degree centrality
between the centrality or you know what
hmm let me try to go back to
presentation mode zoom out a bit as I'm
out a bit zoomed out a little too much
I don't want to dwell too much on this
one so if you didn't complete it it's
okay the main point here is degree
centrality and betweenness centrality
are not perfectly related and I'm just
wondering if you might be able to think
of an example where something would have
high betweenness centrality but not
necessarily a high degree centrality a
part of me a bridge between two
communities perhaps so yes so exactly
that we're talking about a barbell graph
right a barbell graph has two
communities on the side but they're
individual there is an individual or a
set of individuals in the middle through
which if a message wants to go from one
community to the other it always has to
pass through them so this guy doesn't
have a high degree centrality but it's
still nonetheless important for the
network in some ways this network is
also brittle because you remove that guy
then boom the two communities are
isolated all right so any other
questions on this notebook part of me
PageRank is also another centrality
measure absolutely so Google's Google's
secret sauce is all based off centrality
measures and you know graphs and
networks and stuff as well so it's also
proof that networks are have great
applications in the real world it's not
just some theoretical thing that we're
dealing with in this tutorial
that's a tough one I cannot think one of
one off the top of my head but I can
maybe try to imagine a structure where
say one of these guys out here so this
one might have a relative to the rest of
the network it's got a fairly high
degree centrality it's not the highest
perhaps in that you know all of these
are connected to one another though
actually so yeah so this one would have
a fairly high degree centrality but it's
between the centrality isn't necessarily
very high because messages don't always
have to pass through that individual to
get from this side to that side that's
sort of like a weak example though they
message so between us is the number of
shortest paths that pass through
perfectly connected network would have
that's a tough one yeah yeah so that
would be a tough edge case to
qualitatively define I'd have to think
about that yeah okay that's a that's an
example of how centrality measures can
be used in different ways and your sorry
how different centrality measures have
different interpretations in a real
world network so with that let's see
we're doing good with time let's jump
over oh yes
yes it does it has the PageRank score
for nodes inside a network as well okay
so with cliques triangles and squares
which is the next notebook I only intend
to go through the first exercise and
leave it at that because the second
exercise the first exercise is
sufficient to give you an understanding
of finding structures in a network all
right so let's open up notebook number
four now so in a network in a social
network for example if everyone knows
everybody that's a clique that's the
definition of a clique right if there's
one individual in that group that
doesn't know one person then that clique
is no longer a clique so well what you
can think of is then the simplest clique
is two nodes with bi-directional edges
going between them and the simplest
complex clique would be a triangle right
in a triangle everyone knows everybody
then you've got more complex cliques
which you have four nodes and then
you've got a whole lot of triangles
inside there so really more complex
cliques can be decomposed into lots of
triangles and so what we're going to do
in this notebook is we're gonna look for
figure out how to write the code to find
triangles in a network and triangles
have special meaning
there's geometric meanings there's you
know real-world social meanings etc we
hope that you know most stable
relationships are not marital
relationships are not triangle
relationships so yes there's their
special meaning to some of this stuff as
well so this really stems from the
problem and so sorry let me backtrack a
little bit if you have a trying an open
triangle that actually forms business
opportunities is what
so if a nozbe and NOC is it likely that
be also no see right and this is
actually if you combine this knowledge
of the network structure with other
metadata you know what's the demographic
information of B and C etc you can put a
probability distribution on whether to
recommend B to connect with C on
LinkedIn and that's actually open
triangles where exactly the way that
LinkedIn started doing their friend
recommend or colleague recommendation
algorithms now they probably have
something much more complicated than
what I'm describing but the core idea is
there to look for open triangles so if
we skip that what we're going to do in
this what we're going to do in this
notebook just for this next 10 minutes
or so is we're going to look for
triangles inside a network all right so
the the core idea so how would you find
a triangle right that's it's essentially
a path traversal problem where you have
to go 1 degree 2 degree and then three
degrees of separation out from yourself
and back to yourself right that's
essentially what a triangle is you have
to be able to trace a path back to
yourself three degrees of separation
away or if you want to put in another
way then the neighbor if my my neighbors
neighbors neighbors should include
myself that's another way of looking at
it right that the degree of separation
isn't it's it's also phrased in that
particular way so I'm a little bit
unclear did I give you guys this code
inside the notebook is this set of code
present there no right great so I'd like
you to try to implement that algorithm
then you probably if you if you were
fast enough you probably saw that bit of
code flashed up on the screen you
probably have an idea of the structure
if you didn't then perfect please give
it a shot
let me see if let me check that I forgot
what the prompt requirements were in
triangle so it should return a true or
false
and if we're done with this exercise
we'll be done with this notebook I
really would like to give you all a
flavor for how we do statistical
inference on networks in a bit using
hacker methods
so just a quick show of hands how are
people doing anybody done okay we have a
few hands done I'm gonna give it just
two more minutes this is definitely one
of the tougher problems inside the
notebook it's not the toughest the
toughest one is yet to come but so I'm
just gonna give it a few more minutes we
don't have to have quorum on this
problem to proceed the core idea is if
you know how to write a path traversal
algorithm to find stuff you should be
able to implement this on your own and
you should and have the flexibility
really it's all about the flexibility in
the mindset to be able to write your own
code that solves graphs problems right
if something's not implemented you
should be able to take the API and
implement it for yourself and then
hopefully also put in a pull request to
network X and then improve the package
as well
okay I'm gonna flash up the I'm gonna
flash up the answer just really quickly
we have a node I asked I query for its
neighbors and I go three you'll notice I
have neighbors too and neighbors three
so it's a really inefficient
implementation you probably could think
of a better implementation this is the
clearest way that I know how to present
this concept in code and so that's
basically it all right and then you know
we finally do the check if I am in my
neighbors three lists then I am in a
triangle relationship with other people
so but of course what the meaning of
that triangle relationship that's a
different thing so like I was saying
network X already has a function that
counts the number of triangles and so
you can actually use that to say am I in
a triangle relationship it counts to
zero then you know you're not and if
your counts anything more than zero then
you are this code above was simply for
practice okay so we're going to skip the
rest of this notebook in the interest of
time before we move on questions yes
triangles are the fundamental clique in
my opinion or sorry they are the
simplest complex clique so you can use
triangles to query for higher order
clicks creeks that involve other nodes
that's my argument okay so we're gonna
skip the rest of this notebook
there are challenge coding problems at
the bottom recently I read stuff on how
to do statistics for hackers and so I'd
really like to adapt show you content
that I've adapted to network statistics
and how you can do statistical inference
on networks so notebook number five in
the interim is a notebook that shows you
how to load data from a CS
we file into a network X graph that you
can start to play with it's sort of in
my opinion it's not the most important
thing that I wanted to convey to you so
I've given you all of the code you can
modify it you can change it for your own
purposes if you ever have network
problems that you need to solve in the
future so we're gonna skip number five
as well so if you could please open up
notebook number six right and and of
course load run the first cell so that
we're going run the first cell so that
we're ready to go so like I was
mentioning in this network we're going
to walk through hackers approach to
cystic statistical thinking but now
applied to network analysis so I hope I
don't have to emphasize this too much
statistics really can be broken down
into two things one descriptive
statistics so in other words you've got
a bunch of data and you need to
summarize it for your boss you give
something like the mean the IQR etc and
then but that's that's descriptive stats
and then there's inferential stats which
is basically saying this data that I
observed you either ask what's the
probability that it came from some
random model well actually sorry that's
right
you are asking what's the probability
that it came from some random model for
the purpose of asking whether that if
that random model represents pure
randomness that's meaningless then you'd
say it may or may not have happened by a
chance or if that random model carries
some particular mechanistic meaning then
you'd say yes my data fits this
particular model of randomness all right
so that's inferential statistics so like
I was mentioning descriptive statistics
essentially goes into this idea of you
know measures of centrality and we're
not talking about Network centrality
anymore we're talking about net
centrality of a distribution so if you
have a distribution of data there's the
mean the median the mode and then
there's variance measures the interval
I'll arrange the variance and its square
root the standard deviation if you're
doing and then there's inferential stats
which I was like I was mentioning
earlier it's all about models of
randomness hypothesis testing or fitting
statistical models all right so I'm not
gonna go into any I'm not gonna mention
it here their models randomness please
take a look at them for yourself they're
very useful to be familiar with the only
one that we're going to use today is the
binomial distribution
which is what this synthetic social
network was based on so what we're going
to do is we're going to test whether
this synthetic social network came from
a particular parametric parameterised
distribution of ER networks or those
brand new networks all right so just to
give you an idea for the ER network the
ER network basically works like this if
I have a set of nodes then and and I put
in a probability P then every edge
that's present inside there has the
probability P of being existent so we're
flipping a coin we're iterating over the
edges and we're saying do we add an edge
do we not add an edge do we add an edge
do we not add an edge and then we'll get
some distribution of edges across the
network all right so if you could read
in the social network the synthetic
social network that I've provided and
just very quickly
rique weari the number of nodes and
edges this synthetic social network I'm
going to spill the beans and say yes it
is an ER Network I it's the most
convenient network that you can that I
came up that I that I could identify at
that time so if I have n nodes so I want
to pose this question to you all self
edges are not allowed if I have n nodes
and M edges and I assume that the graph
came from an ER graph what's a
reasonable estimate for the value of P
right so I've got some data and I need
to estimate the value of P in the ER
model that generates
that likely generated my data so what do
you guys think back there so the the
number of edges average number of edges
okay alright so that's a plausible
answer okay that's a bit more fancy okay
yep
yep - 2 over N 2 over n minus 1 ok so
I'm not going to give an answer just yet
all right because this is all about
statistical inference you have your
measure of P hat so what I want you to
try to do is to take a stab and guess
what you think would be P hat and write
down your estimate for the value of P
all right so I've like I was saying I've
given you the procedure for generating
an ER graph what's the value of P
just to spoil the beans right at the
beginning of the instructor version of
the notebook I'm giving the wrong answer
and it's on purpose
assuming selfloops are allowed
assuming selfloops are allowed so yes so
work with your assumptions right that's
a that's all that's a lot of this is
statistics at action in action so I have
my answer don't copy it if you don't
want to you can copy it if you want to
if you had your own own answer work with
it okay so my answer which is incorrect
but if you'll tolerate me for a little
few moments my initial answer is M over
N squared
all right so going forth the next thing
I want you to do is to use the network X
function very dos brand new graph to
create a single ER graph using your
computed value of P hat so it would be
if you imported Network X as NX you
would do NX dot erdos-renyi graph you
pass in N and you pass in P and if
you're familiar with statistics this is
exactly the binomial it looks exactly
like the binomial distribution
parameters and so make sure your ER
graph has the same number of nodes as
the synthetic social network
all done if you're done please raise
your thumb
okay I see if your hands see another one
okay I'm gonna just give you guys my
answer over there I'm using very generic
parameters so you know you can copy it
it's no problem so the next thing I want
you to do is to plot the degree
connectivity distribution of the ER
network that you've created and sort the
distribution of degree connectivity's
from highest to lowest and then plot
this on a mat plot lid plot and in the
interest of time I'm just going to show
you my answer and I want you to do it
and so you can copy it and and what I'm
really trying to do get out here is to
get this idea of the distribution the
sampling distribution out front and
center okay so if you take a look at
that now I went fancy with the
matplotlib API so you know legends
labels colors etc you don't have to for
my incorrect version incorrect value of
P hat you'll notice that the ER graph
that I have doesn't follow the same
degree distribution as the synthetic
social network all right and so if you
think about it the ER network that you
had created comes from a particular
model of comes from a particular
statistical model of how networks are
formed right and the procedure I've
described to you iterate through every
possible edge and then flip a coin you
know how many is is there what's the
probability of that what's the
probability of that edge existing inside
the network the space of all
hypothetical ER graphs that could happen
is the full distribution and the space
that you sample out is the sampling
distribution right so in
if you look at Jake van der placid
slides which I'm referencing at the
bottom statistics for hackers the
sampling distribution is hard too hard
to and sometimes hard to analytically
define but it's usually easy to simulate
if you have a generative model like this
so just now the ER graph that you had
drawn came from one instance of the
sampling distribution so what I'd like
you to try to do now is to let's move on
beyond this figure out the sampling
distribution of the mean degree of yeah
so figure out the sampling distribution
of the mean degree mean degree
centrality from a thousand tries or
hundred tries samples of this synthetic
network so I'm gonna give you the answer
to the mean the mean degree distribution
and then I'd like you to work on the
next exercise below
and like I was saying the mean that you
get for your synthetic network might not
be the same as the mean that I get but
I'd like you to just give that a quick
shot
yes I'm intentionally giving you this so
that I'd you don't have to worry about
futzing around with in-network x api and
sorry the numpy api in Python 3 there's
a few issues a few bugs there the the
key line is this guy and then you can do
the analogous for the synthetic social
network alright so if you move on
draw 1000 instances from N equals 30 P
equals your thing your P hat value and
return the mean value inside there
are people doing
hmmm looks like we need a last-minute
change of strategy that's okay so I'm
gonna basically show you the I'm going
to talk through the rest of this
notebook in the interest of time and
then hopefully I'll have conveyed this
idea of using a hacker simulation method
rather than you know analytical math if
your algebra blind like me then you know
the hacker method might be a more
suitable way so basically what we're
doing here is we're calculating the
degree distribution over here we're
sorry we're drawing a thousand instances
of the ER graph and then we're figuring
out the degree distribution and then
we're calculating the mean we're storing
the mean in the numpy array and then we
look at and so we have the distribution
of mean values over a thousand instances
if we plot that you'll get something
like that and if you plot where the
synthetic network existed its way out
here so what's the so that it's quite
like just visually it's quite likely
that you know we don't have this network
coming from an N equals 30 P equals 0.05
right but so this is so this is like if
you did the hypothesis test you know the
probability of seeing this would be very
very low however if you want to do model
fitting you might tweak the parameter P
hat and you might say let's recalculate
it based on some new formula and then if
you draw it it's out over there all
right and so what I was hoping to what
I'm hoping to convey to you all is that
if you have a network and you want to
calculate whether this network came from
some particular model go simulate a
hundred a thousand trials of that
network and and measure some statistic
that you can compare the distribution of
the statistic that you can compare
between the simulated trials and the
thing that you've met and and the
network that you have network data that
you have on hand just to give you a few
more references a lot
this was inspired by this set of slides
and this blog post so please go up there
and check it out the final thing I want
you to do is a little fun activity so
we've reached the end but the one last
thing I want you to do is this there is
a business card that's on the seats I
want to become a hub node as measured by
high degree centrality
I want you I want to be in the triangle
Conference relationships with all of you
all so please write your name and email
on the back of that card and then find
someone to exchange that card with all
right and so and if you have your own
business card go ahead if you don't have
the card please pick it up if you need a
pen there should be two pilot g two pens
circulating around if not i can i can
pass this around to this was all about
networks so hopefully we got a chance to
have you all network with one another as
well and with that thank you very much